Marjorie Taylor green you put her on a
new subcommittee to investigate the
origins of covet yes she compared mask
requirements to the type of abuse Jews
were subjected to during the Holocaust
she called for fauci to be arrested and
imprisoned and she spread conspiracy
theories how's anyone supposed to take
that work seriously and find that work
credible very well you look at all of it
so you have all the questions out there
I think what the Americans you think
these are legitimate questions I think
what the American public wants to see is
an open dialogue in the process this is
a select committee where people can have
all the questions they want and you'll
see the outcome open dialogue we're just
asking questions this is this is the
work of conspiracy theory this is how
they act this is what they say well
we're just asking questions what's wrong
with asking questions
and when you put someone like this as
pernicious and Sinister and indeed
stupid as Marjorie Taylor green on this
committee it diminishes the work that
they will do